[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
maybe
[Music]
so
[Music]
what's going on realm all right so
here's the rules of engagement for this
show all right so
um i will say it again at the beginning
of the show but i want to make it clear
here too
uh this uh megan does work for obsidian
but
i don't want people thinking
we're just gonna believe her with
questions in the chat that we know for a
fact she can't answer
this is about her writing life about
what it takes for a developer to be a
writer i know the view is going to be
low on this one uh because
it it's going to be more educational
than entertainment wise and that's fine
i'm okay with that uh but you know we're
gonna make it fun though you guys know
how i am i'ma make it fun and i hope you
guys enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is there something going on with the
chat nick nicks i i don't see anything
yet but
i'm not really paying attention on 100
of things going on right now
this is kind of done at the last minute
a little bit
our guest should be here momentarily uh
so
keep that in mind you know i got i got
the waiting room on so uh i see when she
pops up so i can
re
mute the chat you know i want to engage
a little bit don't want you guys sitting
in that starting zoom screen too much
oh yeah i mean
oh okay okay okay
i get what you're saying now you know
like i said
for those who don't know
share
the podcast on twitter do whatever you
guys can get these numbers
you know i know when it comes to
educational videos because we're going
to go over a lot of you know a lot of
questions revolve writing it doesn't it
doesn't really
relate to a lot of people and i
understand that so i do feel like
i am going to have to
find another way of doing these type of
videos that's not the attic show because
you guys want the attic show you want us
talking you know you want me and hustle
shooting it up that's what you guys want
and i respect that
so you know i'll probably do another
show uh whenever i have these type of
stuff uh and it will be closer to like
maybe the end of the week when i do have
them like on a friday
because i do have the attic spotlight
for any of you long-term listeners you
guys know that uh i do have that so
that's where i'll probably make these
into that
uh but right now i gotta see exactly
what what i do with these man
i'm excited i'm waiting uh for megan to
uh to get in here she's
she she's busy person man she's a big
busy person
uh once she gets here we'll start i'm
assuming she'll be here in like the next
10 minutes
uh so you know we
we're gonna have a good time man uh you
know put in the comments section below
if there's any particular questions that
you guys would want me to ask now
obviously
i'm not gonna answer ask all them i
might answer some of them ask or some of
them just depending on what the
questions are
and keep in mind it's got it's got to be
related a lot to
the writing portion of her job
okay
while we have time can you tell us how
you make the fire the green screen
oh my god that is not me i don't i don't
walk around like that man
it's not me
i don't have
fire around me man i'm not on fire nix
i'm not on fire
actually um
i'm kind of a blanket who made that that
intro let me wrote you guys it's kind of
a blank i don't
i can't remember
who made it we have a lot of people make
stuff i think it was shauna bray i think
it was sean labrie but i don't know
uh megan
stark is a
senior writer
on the obsidian team she writes uh for
uh the outer worlds that's the team she
writes for
but like i said you know we're uh this
this podcast is going to be directed
around
that particular role i'm going to i got
a lot of good questions for you know i
spent
a good hour hour and a half
writing questions and deleting questions
uh because i do there are some questions
that i like to ask but you know
obviously
i don't want to dig too much into
the outer worlds i want to use it more
as a reference point
than anything
because here here's here's the thing
that i i do and like i said i'm going to
go over all this
when the show starts
i feel like
we're even guilty we have a lot of
developers on we have a lot of industry
people but it's always about
you know
for the company they work for
and i want to do more
to give back to the people who
okay she's here i'll talk to you guys in
a minute
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
and
[Music]
what's going on guys attic shop i
apologize uh for the tardiness uh you
know i'll take all the blame for that
that was totally my fault
so
how we're gonna do this all right first
off i've said this multiple times in the
starting soon screen uh but some of you
guys are stubborn
i don't care if you super chat anything
we're not answering questions about
outer worlds too
because they
these people they they thirsty man they
do whatever they can whatever they can
we will not be asking questions about
stuff related to that uh for the most
part we won't even really talk about the
senior projects you know we might uh
use
stuff to happen in the first one as like
at an objective standpoint but we're not
talking about anything it's gonna be
about the writing and the reason i'm
making these these segments is i do feel
like a lot of you on twitter you know i
feel like a lot of you feel like you can
do jaws better than other people and
it's not really our fault i do feel like
you know we we we need to ask people
more questions you know we need to be
enlightened more educated on the matter
so that's what i'm doing man this is the
the day in the life of a senior writer
in the gaming industry you know what's
funny megan when i was right doing the
title on youtube i was like i don't know
if i want to put obsidian into the title
so i just used your name i didn't put it
oh sure
that's fine either way i mean it's not
like we come after you
well it's not that it's just but it's
not about that time i know yeah i know
how pr is it
and part of the reason i i want to do
this too is i want to
give an outlet to where
it feels like
we having because even even the iron
lords podcast you know no one does it
on purpose
but it's like you you were on the show
to talk about your job you know what i'm
saying to talk about working for
obsidian and i feel like there's not a
lot of opportunities for devs to come on
and just talk about them as a person you
know what i'm saying
that's another reason i'm doing this
because i i i'm more curious on the dev
side than anything else but i don't
really get to like
stretch that muscle too much so it's
going to be nice to have a good
conversation but so uh first off we'll
get to like the opening stuff megan like
what what are you playing here lately
any type of games that you like are you
playing here that's released
um well most recently i was playing um
tiny tina's wonderlands which i really
like because i'm a big borderlands fan
anyway i've heard recently like when
i've talked to people it seems like
borderlands humor or the ip is very like
hit or miss for folks either love it or
hate it but i've always been like
a pretty big fan um it was enjoying that
i like the couch co-op there's this kind
of limited amount of games you can play
couch co-op on
and before that
i was pretty into
hades i put a lot of hours into that
which i was late to the game i think i
was like two years late to play in that
but it was really fun yeah hades is a is
a pretty fun game i like the art style
and
not a lot of
you know type of gameplay like that that
really resonate with me but i don't know
why maybe it's just because
that's like mythology and because of
games like uh god of war i grew up with
that kind of uh greek mythology well i
was just blown away that that game only
had one writer and i was like oh my gosh
like hats off to that guy that's really
impressive person was probably writing
24 7.
i know right the way that they did it
was really interesting too because you
can tell that it must have been like
just tons and tons of like excel sheets
or however they organize it with all
these conditionals on it and then it's
plugged in and then they fire
you know randomly and i just thought it
was really cool
yeah so you know we're going to go ahead
and
rotate because obviously i don't want to
keep you too long you work enough
uh you know
first thing i would like to know is you
know we obviously have a lot of uh going
into
you know a lot of different roles at
different companies in general i want to
know what's what it's like for a day as
megan
as being a senior writer what's like the
day-to-day life when it comes to that
kind of term
um well
um it kind of depends at what point in
the project we're on because
sometimes i'll just be a senior
narrative designer sometimes i'm strike
team lead
sometimes i'm
in charge of people making
you know a zone in the game
or a feature like companions
but just from the writing perspective
uh i guess it would be like come in
check your email see if there's anything
that's like jump to the top of the to-do
or you need to respond to
check when your meetings are you'll
typically be assigned
to either like some studios call them
pods some call them strike teams but
it's typically like a narrative designer
an area designer an environment artist
and maybe like a qa person and you guys
are a group and you're in charge of
either a feature or an area of the game
and you're going to meet regularly and
develop all the content in there like in
sync with each other um so you might
have meetings where you're discussing
what's the next thing we're working on
or what's the status of this task and
then yeah i just have different you know
types of tasks like lately it's been a
lot of
conversations for characters so you know
like quest giver vendors um
dungeon villains stuff like that
and then i just
get latest open up tools do my writing
and play test it
oh that that's that's interesting i've
always you know we'll get into that a
little bit about like the cooperations
between you and other departments i've
always wondered like how in-depth that
is but i do have a question related to
that so
um
just just so the audience knows uh what
what projects have you worked on in the
gaming industry
um
so uh previously my first job was at
icarus studios working on fall on earth
um which was in post-apocalyptic mmo
hold on like were you seeing my like
work messages pop up might need to close
out of this program okay so i was like
people are messaging me like oh hey by
the way
um okay
uh after that i worked on um at carbine
studios on wildstar um and then after
that i came to obsidian i worked on
tyranny i worked on pillars of eternity
two dead fire i worked on the outer
worlds and then i worked on both of the
outer worlds dlcs and now i'm on uh the
outer world sequel
that's that's just for like the
viewership-wise i i do okay like as far
as
you know you've worked on the out awards
for a good amount of time has there ever
been a popular franchise that you've
seen that you was just like you've
always been curious off of maybe a
certain writing portion that you saw
maybe a certain character development in
the game then you was like you've been
very curious that you would actually
like to work for that team on that game
if you ever had a chance was there any
like franchise that you could think of
um yeah i mean i have a ton of games
that i play and i just feel like i'm a
huge fan um i've always liked um
mentioned before borderlands i've always
liked bioshock i've always liked fallout
most recently control absolutely like
got obsessed with that um so i feel like
any of those type of games would just be
super fun to work on also i like um
x-men and so the
um wolverine game that they're making i
think looks really cool but again it's
like you know i'm pretty happy
with what i'm doing now so that's more
just like i guess if you're gonna
imagine oh what would it be like if i
wanted to you know work on a project
like that or whatever any of those would
be super exciting oh yeah i definitely i
feel like you know when it comes to
especially rpgs uh you know i i feel
like
writing in those would be like crazy
like keep it keep you busy it'll keep
you busy man it'll keep you busy what
about what about you know when it comes
to rpgs you know i want to specialize a
little bit on rpgs because you've been
working on the most uh you know you did
mention fallout uh is there any other
type of huge rpgs that you've played
over the years that you would like to
i've literally put like no joke for like
because you can see the stats when you
load up and say follow it i put like 400
hours into witcher 3
with our dlc's and i heard they're
making another dlc so i'm like yeah
um i played cyberpunk uh
you know i enjoyed it but it didn't like
i didn't get obsessed with it the same
way that i did with witcher 3 but i mean
you know everyone has their own
preferences so that's more just a flavor
thing
yeah i hear you on that all right so
when it comes to you know the witcher
what what is some characters in the
witcher 3 that you really gravitated
towards
this is like controversial this is like
fandom stuff i really like jennifer
i know she's like a lot of people like
love or hate her i like jennifer i like
siri i like carol um all of the witchers
in both um the game and the television
series i think are really cool like
the more of them the better
yeah i feel like series uh
in particular like she's a really unique
character
takes on like a different aspect of just
about everything uh i really like how
the tv show has like kind of like
filled more lore behind everyone i know
some people don't like it some people do
uh i've always been the kind of person
like when it comes to any type of tv
entertainment i've always been that i'm
trying to be unbiased as possible
obviously uh you know stuff like halo
i i was very vocal about uh but you know
you know speaking of of of
of xbox in general uh you know they got
a lot of studios now and now let's get
away from rpg and everything uh you know
any any studio microsoft has that if you
were decided that you know i want to i
want to go somewhere else and you had
the opportunity to go anywhere in xbox
and all their studios what's the one
that you'd be more open to doing
because there's a lot and we you know
we won't use the activision ones so just
the studios that they currently have now
what's the studio that you've always
liked you know what that would be fun to
write with
i mean i think like i kind of had my
pick and i was lucky to get in an
obsidian but
i you know i wouldn't leave it so
it's hard to imagine like
you know if for some reason
i was ever like oh hey
because you're already at microsoft and
you're staying here but we also want you
to write for whatever project yeah i
mean i think anything
that bethesda or arcane is putting out
is really okay um yeah i really enjoyed
pray um obviously dishonored although
that's some france uh that was really
cool and i'm interested to play
my brain is blanking as it red fall or
sorry i'm messing that up okay yeah i
was like i saw the trailer of that look
really cool i'd heard a little bit about
it um before i saw the trailer but i
thought yeah i'm definitely going to
play that as well
so but i guess those are a little bit
similar like i do like the rp
you know genre so it's kind of in the
same vein
yeah i actually you know i'm a huge fan
of arcane actually like i really love
dishonored i love death luke i i felt
like the writing death loop was really
good the writing of death loop was
really good all right so let's say
france
let's go ahead and get into the nitty
gritty man let's
obviously
there's all types of different
characters you can write being a writer
especially in the gaming industry what
is what is that one
type of right writer when you're writing
a character of some of sort that you
would think is the hardest in general
like what type of character
that would be a difficult right that you
would have to take on
i really think it's different per writer
like every writer has their own
strengths and weaknesses and their own
personal interests and also a lot of it
can be based off of like you know your
life experiences and the type of
media and you know other writing and
shows and stuff that you like to consume
so
for me i particularly like to write like
anti-hero and villain type characters
it's a little bit harder for me to write
like a typical like you know goody goody
white knight um but i feel like with
most people it's like the opposite where
they kind of gravitate more towards like
like it actually would have been really
difficult for me
to write parvati and do her justice in
the way that kate did you know because
parvati is such a sweet
like supportive
multi-layered you know interesting
character that i probably would have
fumbled it honestly um
but you know writing a
robot who doesn't care if you go on a
murder spree or whatever is much easier
for me um but yeah for other people they
might not enjoy writing villains the
same way so i think it kind of just
depends on your personal interests and
what you've practiced and stuff like
that yeah actually uh anti-heroes i'm
sure that that's a pretty fun area to
explore because
like if if you stick to like a typical
hero or typical villain you kind of
gotta go one way or the other like you
could you could start to branch a little
bit but like when you dig these these
these personalities like
by lore wise and by what makes sense
they're gonna go left or right again but
when it comes like an anti-hero like you
could just wake up okay i feel like this
particular scene
he's going to be straight left and then
straight right the week after i i've
always felt like when it comes to
anti-heroes like they're always
uniquely written because
at any time
they could go anywhere you would never
expect it uh so i i like that i like
that that was that that's a nice uh
little touch uh you know
i obviously with rpgs you know we've
talked a lot about rpgs but one thing
i'm curious about is you know let's say
that you
[Music]
uh you know you end up eventually
wanting to go into another genre is
there every type of other genre that
you'd like you know action adventure you
know we even talk about uh you know
i would say probably
rts's because i would say look the
gameplay is not really particularly the
thing that you would deal with but when
you make a story you uh you know
obviously we'll get into the
collaborations between departments was
ever another genre that you know was
interest you like you know uncharted the
last
lanes
i think um genre for video games is a
little bit different than genre for like
novels so like a lot of times in novels
if you're talking about genre you're
straight up saying like oh is this
sci-fi it's a cyberpunk is this fantasy
but like with video games a lot of times
it's like
what is the
type of combat what is the type of
gameplay and then within that what is
the you know is it a
fantasy setting um
do you have a predefined hero is it a
linear story is it branching dialogue i
think for me
the type of you know combat
and
type of gameplay experience i wouldn't
be like oh i prefer this over another
but if i was going to try something else
i think it would be pretty cool to do a
linear story
um something very cinematic kind of like
you know uncharted or
last of us um
or even you know control was a little
bit in that vein i would say so i just
thought those experiences are pretty
cool and i haven't actually written on
them before because
i mostly did mmos and then now i'm doing
rpgs so that would be a new um adventure
for me
and i think linear projects too you
would have obviously like you know going
into the branching things that most
typical rpgs do
you can't really like
completely go one direction because you
always have to give uh give the
characters multiple directions so i feel
like you know do because i always felt
like certain games that drive away and
try to give him more of an open dialogue
stuff it's like i always felt like
it didn't make sense for certain scenes
like because when a linear thing you
know the reason people love joel the
reason people love ellie the reason
people love nathan drake you know laura
croft because uh they the writers were
able to write the story in such a way
because there was a bunch of branching
options and i feel like you look rpgs
make sense you know because
you want to give the player as much
options as possible because that's
generally what an rpg is but when it
comes to like linear stuff you want to
tell a story
that's the number one focus over
everything i would say probably gameplay
but we're talking about writing so
as far as telling the story that is the
most important thing and i think in in
rpgs it's kind of the story is important
but options is the most important thing
to an rpg and i think that's probably
why a lot of writers might want to write
a linear because they would feel like
they can go complete extra on a story
because they know that every person is
going to come across that story not just
the people that go down that branch
that's true um i think
uh
both have their like strengths and
weaknesses or unique challenges right so
it could be a little bit of a grasses
greener like when you're working on a
branching
game or a game that has to account for
so many different like did the player do
this but not that or are they this build
and you know uh any one thing you add
like say i was like oh it would be
really cool
if you know you can read this report um
that this other character wrote well now
i need the option to go back to that
character and say hey i found this thing
let's talk about it right so like any
little thing you want to add it has like
a domino effect of like now you got to
make sure all these other things account
for it um so and you have to like when
you're building out a conversation go
okay well what if the player goes here
here here here but not there so maybe
you have like eight different routes
through a conversation you have to count
for all those it can seem like a lot of
moving parts and be like oh you know
it's it can be overwhelming wouldn't it
be so easy if like well there was only
one route but i think when you're
looking at a linear game where the focus
is on the cinematic
story and you know having a really
strong protagonist and a really strong
conflict that they have to overcome um
it's almost like eye of sauron or like
you have to be like the top one percent
like it has to be immaculate you know so
like you might be working on the same
thing over and over and over and
scrapping it revising it and just having
like multiple versions of that one thing
that's trying to push it towards
perfection so i think it's actually
probably
very similar just um different methods
yeah i definitely would agree with you
on that and you know
his famous lie it is you know just one
because he feels like you know those
type of games especially uh because that
story narrative do really good
so i've always wondered this and i
i don't know how this works but
for years i've wondered this when you're
making a story
what comes first the world that the
story's being told in or the story that
the world is is being told it like i'm
kind of i don't know if you like
understand that it didn't really say it
the way i said in my mind like
let's say you have a world
i feel like
i don't know if
development process is to develop the
world first or develop the story and the
artists create the world off of what the
imag like what the story inclines if
that makes sense how does that generally
go is it generally like i would feel
like it varies but in your experiences
from working with other
departments do you have a lot of input
on how they do stuff like that and you
know as far as the world creation do you
have any input on that as well
i think it depends on how high level
you're looking at so if it's something
like you know the game creators um
you know in the very beginning
and literally it's like blank page
nothing has been defined like i would
actually be interested to find out like
you know to ask tim and leonard like did
you decide on like the world and the
setting and then the storyline i would
imagine they probably started with um
that was saying like hey this is the
type of world or the type of
you know universe that this is going to
live in and then within that what type
of stories can we tell because it's just
you always have to put some constraints
on it you have to pick a direction and
start to define it and like make a
little box for yourself otherwise
you know
you could never like move forward or get
anything done so i think they would
probably pick some constraints like that
and then decide what type of story to
tell within that it could easily go the
other way like a different type of
creator on a different game maybe he had
an idea for
you know the main character and their
struggle and then just built a world
around that i think either would work
when you get down to the smaller level
um
a lot of times
we've already defined like these are the
areas you can go to in the game and then
within that we decide you know these are
the characters that are going to show up
here and this is the type of things the
player is going to do so i do think a
lot of times it can be more
what worlds are you building first yeah
yeah what's funny is uh i've seen a lot
of uh especially writing teams use what
i like to call the rico board where it's
like you know how like the fbi try to
take down people and they have like a
giant board with like connecting dots to
everyone it's like i've seen so many
like writing teams have something
similar it's like this is the writing
portion and it has like a line that goes
to this i think i think that's unique
and i like stuff like that all right so
i'm kind of curious on this now
obviously we were talking about type of
gameplay that's in in gaming um does the
writers have any impact into that
whatsoever on you know because to to me
like we were talking about the linear
thing um
it would determine how you write a story
off the type of game play it is uh so it
is when a writer is brought on board for
you know something like uh a project is
that already predetermined or does
everyone come together to talk about
that type of thing before you write a
story related to
how the combat would particularly
because you can only write the story but
i do feel like as far as the player
it would depend on how that combat's
done to really hyphen that story that
you're writing do you have any type of
input on that at all
um yes i think it can go either way and
a lot of times it does sometimes you
know combat team will say hey we have
villain and they can fly or you know
they float in this stage and then you're
like okay let me figure out a way to
write that into the storyline and kind
of foreshadow it and so it doesn't just
come out of nowhere or you know let me
write combat lines that back that up um
sometimes like for example on um
the dlc murder on eredanos because we
knew it was like a murder mystery and we
wanted players to be able to role play
like what type of detective they are we
thought well it'd be really cool if you
had like a sci-fi gadgety magnifying
glass and then we asked you know the
systems team like we worked with them to
to
create the discrepancy amplifier and
like how that would work oh
my poor kitty he tried to jump on the
desk and didn't quite make it so um and
normally my desk is like lower down when
i'm riding but it's standing us right
now um but anyway so we worked with them
to say like how should this work
um you know what type what does it look
like when you find evidence in the game
um and that was really like the story
requesting um a gameplay element added
but a lot of times the gameplay element
is already there and then you're it's
your job to like
explain that and make it fit in with the
world and build that into the experience
narratively
so pretty much what you're saying is
it's it's a mixture of both sometimes
it's a predetermined thing then you know
maybe
midway through something gets added and
then they're like yo we got this boss
that floats uh can we add him in some
way and then you got to go back to the
drawing board and find a way that makes
sense to put that particular person in
the game
that's interesting if we just walk in
one day has there um
is that that's interesting i i i
actually like that because because it
shows that you guys are what's what i'm
looking for
um at any time something can change
oh yeah you can easily well i'm not
gonna say easily but you you you could
go back to the drawing board and make
sure that person makes sense into it you
know as far as like
you look at
positive characters like resident evil
with like wesker like those characters
are probably predetermined for years uh
but you know the the chick that's with
wesker and resident evil 5 maybe she
wasn't and she was how to put it at the
last minute so
that's interesting and i would say that
happens a lot with like like side
characters and certain side quests um
you know we were talking about
departments and stuff i'm curious like
what's the departments that you work
with the most
definitely area design court you know
some studios call it like level design
game design
um basically anyone who's your content
creator who's like you know making the
quest work and building the level that
you're running through
also environment art or
some studios just call it like world art
or
world builders which is you know anybody
who's like
putting the trees in and adding your set
dressing and making it look nice um
because you have to talk with them about
this is
you know what the building is and the
purpose that it serves and let's make
sure that it all fits in the story and
like a lot of times they will you know
push that forward and then i'm just
there to go like yeah that's great or
actually that wouldn't make sense
because of this other thing um you know
to provide context but so it really
depends on
the specific piece of content that
you're making like one person might have
more of an idea or ownership that's
pushing it forward and the other people
are there just to support that and kind
of reference it and then it kind of
varies i'm actually curious has ever
been like something that you've written
in a game
and
the artist comes back with what their
description of what you've written and
then you was like
and you had like key components that you
would want changed that like that wasn't
the thing that you envisioned yes
well this is like a minor thing but um
and honestly like back then i probably
should have just changed on my end but
like you know it's a lot newer but like
for example super minor version of like
how this could work um on tyranny i was
writing one of the companions kills in
shadow and i wrote or yeah i wrote that
she had like red eyes and when the art
went into the game she had yellow eyes
and i was like oh do you mind you know i
know all the other beasts people have
yellow eyes but like i think it would be
cool to help her stand out and like it
would have been easy for me to just go
in and change the my description in the
writing um so if art had like pushed
back on that i could have done that but
they were like yeah sure we'll just
change your eye color and so that's like
a tiny example but that can happen on a
larger level too for sure
that's it that's cool all right so
sorry just real quick dad i think it is
important for someone working in the
industry like if you guys are
considering it and you want to work it's
important to
be collaborative and compromise and go
back and forth so like sometimes the
artist might go yeah no problem but if
they say like hey my schedule won't
really allow for it you know there's
other higher priority things i think
it's important for you not to like be
too precious about any one thing you
know like if you can afford to make the
change and it makes someone else's life
easier then that goes a long way
yeah especially like you know something
as i color would probably be a lot yeah
right
then you just like i don't like the
outfit they have on because then that
that's a different story that that might
take a lot longer than just changing an
eye color and plus you know it's like
you said when it comes to little stuff
like that and the over perspective of
things like you know in hindsight couple
years from now
is it worth
the effort to change
well also every single thing that goes
into a game essentially like has an
order of priority of like there's only
so much amount of time to make things
and there's like this never-ending list
and anything on the bottom is not making
it in it's getting cut right so like you
kind of have to think about where your
stuff stacks up in that in comparison to
other things so if it's like something
really important like this is integral
to this storyline or this companion or
whatever then maybe you guys talk it out
or have meetings and decide what's going
to happen and what else has to get cut
to make this thing happen or you just go
like that's not that important compared
to everything else let's just get rid of
it or do what we can yeah and plus you
know development in general is about
time you know time equals money time uh
you got deadlines that you have to make
so sometimes you have to look at
something because we actually we
interviewed undead labs once and they
said that they they had a lot more uh
stuff they want to do with like vehicle
combat and stuff but
when it came down to it's like you know
you're in a zombie apocalypse does it
even really make sense that you're able
to do something like that anyway uh so
they ended up cutting a lot of that from
the game so i cannot
it and i think that
that would that would be like a hit and
miss with me like something that you
really was feeling and then again ended
up getting cut uh but at the end of the
day that that's that's the job like at
any time something that you could have
probably written for for weeks could be
cut from the game
um
yeah so i got a curious question now
obviously
i'm sure you've seen you know you said
earlier that you're a huge fan of like
bethesda games uh obviously
fallout 4 we had the uh the protagonist
had a voice
before that none of them really
necessarily did
uh from your perspective of writing um i
don't know if you've ever written uh
anything uh to that nature
is it easier to write
content to to write a game when the
actual main character has a voice or do
you think that is especially rpgs it's
important to give that kind of role
playing where they don't have that voice
so i think there's
a difference in the examples that you're
pointing out
so
fallout 4
and outer worlds um so with fallout 4
the players lines were voiced they were
voice acted but i wouldn't say that that
was necessarily like a predefined
character you know like it's not on the
same level of playing you know geralt um
carol is literally like he's a character
he has a set personality the way he's
gonna respond to things you can push him
a little bit of like is he being more
patient or less patient is he like nice
girl or like abrupt carol but you don't
get that full range of like am i a
full-on psycho character or am i like a
snarky mad scientist or you know whereas
i feel like even in fallout 4 it's still
you defining the character and
role-playing within like a set boundary
of like you know
um were you like
the wife with the law degree or were you
the the war hero you know but within
that it's not it wasn't the same as like
oh this is ellie from you know last of
us and we know exactly what that means
you know um
so
whether it's voice acted or not i do
think if the character itself is like
more of an open book and the player is
defining what that character is to them
and who that character's personality is
you have to represent all different
types in all different situations and
really give the player choice to
define that
if it's something more preset like say
um you know the wolverine game that
they're making right now we know exactly
who logan is like kind of what he talks
like what he sounds like the type of
choices he would make and or even you
know the spider-man game that they did
it's like you have to
study that and you have to be able to
convincingly write that character so
that other people go yeah that's right
or like you know that's believable or
this feels right so it's really your job
to be able to conform to an existing ip
and to be able to
you know craft a voice that is
consistent with something that's already
defined um and i would actually say
this can be a little bit controversial
how people feel about fanfic but i would
say if you're someone who like wants to
work in video games
and you like writing fanfic don't feel
bad about that at all because it's a
great way to practice like
look i can like write for characters who
someone else created and i can convince
other people like yes i know how to
write and and these are the characters
like it sounds correct um and it's a
good way to practice all different types
and even if you don't do fanfic if you
just want to practice on your own i
would say take
varied different ips or characters and
like practice writing their dialogue or
scenes with them and being convincing in
that um
and then that will improve your skills
or give you something that you can show
off if you're applying to somewhere and
show people like yeah if you ask me to
write you know wolverine i can do it
because look i was able to write all
these other characters you know like
maybe
look i wrote some sample lines of
handsome jack that's original writing
but it sounds just like him you know so
um that's a great um exercise to do yeah
so um pretty much uh what what i
gathered from that is
when it comes to
when it comes to like writing um
it makes more sense if the character has
a voice if the character already has
predetermined history
uh but if it's a character like the
fallout 4 character or the dovican or
from you know certain other games it
they they have a history but it's not
predetermined it you don't really have
any way of knowing who they are so it's
okay to like let them wander on their
own imagination when it comes to gareth
if he starts sounding like something
that doesn't make sense you're gonna
upset more people even though you gave
other people freedom with him you're
gonna upset more people because that's
not how he would act
yeah
okay yeah for sure
i definitely understand that all right
so
obviously we know that you work on uh
you know uh of
the outer worlds uh it's got a lot of
branching paths in it um what are some
of the difficulties making branching
path options like i feel like you know
i feel like
you know because like obviously we're
talking about like anti-hero question uh
like you know branching paths sometimes
you guys have like three or four like
it's it's kind of crazy and it's like i
said it was like the the ricoh case
where you have like all these branching
paths like uh what is some of the the
biggest difficulties you have making
that cause i'm sure that's not easy like
in the grand scheme of things after the
whole project's done i'm sure there's a
lot a project a lot of time that went
into that
yeah
it is a lot of time so
and it's a lot more words it's a lot
more
tracking and using uh game logic and
scripting and conditionals and stuff
like that so for example if you have
this
conversation that's got 400 nodes in it
maybe players only experience 100 of
those notes or maybe only 50 of those
notes but different players will
experience different ones so it's like
you had to build out 400 just for a
single player to go through it make
choices and hit the 50 that they're
gonna see in their one playthrough you
also have to track
all the choices that they've made
including like their build their
backgrounds things they've done in the
game previously what companions they
have with them what they're wearing what
choices they've made within the
conversation what skills they have um
and then based off of things that
they've said in the conversation you
have to account for that later so later
on the npc is going to respond and react
to that and they have to react to all
the different possible ones but only
show you the correct matched up version
and so it's a lot of like any one thing
that you see in the game you know
there's probably like
four to eight versions of that and
you're seeing the one that corresponds
to your specific unique playthrough yeah
so
um you know playing a lot of you know
we'll take like an example of obsidian
like certain guests will be with you and
they'll they'll acknowledge that they're
there you know so pretty much what
you're saying is like you have to take
that perspective and like look like
right now we got this person with this
or we got that companion with us but we
have to also write if we have varieties
of every one of the other ones you know
is i don't know if i can't remember if
there's ways in obs uh in in the outer
world not to have companions i'm pretty
sure you could yes you have to account
for you have no companions or you have
to count for which companions you have
and basically that requires you check
for you have a version and check for all
companions and then you have a version
that checks for no companions
and then and then though sometimes your
companions will communicate with each
other so talk to you
there's branching password you can have
a certain like and obviously the
majority of the time they're unique
conversations it's not like you know
they're saying that the same two
companions say the same thing you know
you have a companion and then a
different companion at the different
time you go through they're gonna have a
different conversation
i can't
that that just makes my brain hurt to
think of all that like and then it is
part of your job to hook it up and make
sure it works correctly so it's not just
you know writing the one line that ellie
says you know you have to do
every companion and you have to like you
know hook it up to make sure the
conversation connects properly and has
the right um conditionals or
prerequisites and
then you have to test it all the
different
ways you could possibly go through the
conversation
and i'm assuming like because there's
skill checks too
through all most of these type of games
and then you gotta account for that like
it's got to read the game like do they
have this amount of skill and then that
might change the dialogue again and then
you have to do it again through this way
like yeah that's crazy i don't envy that
man you guys you guys you guys guys are
crazy but it is really fun you know like
you do have a lot of options when you're
building out a conversation so you can
have a lot of fun with it
yeah and especially um you know being a
robot too you
you you could be say some off-the-wall
stuff that that wouldn't make sense
anyone i was saying but it's a robot and
i think that you know when when you talk
from a perspective of a non-human person
it's a lot easier
to justify him doing anything you want
him to because he's not human
that's interesting all right so
obviously we were talking about like
last of us and stuff like that what i
want to ask you is
from your perspective as a writer
what do you think
is easier type of gameplay for you to
get
your writing across to the to the gamer
the best like a first person or a third
person type of game third person for you
actually think that camera it does not
affect the story as much um as maybe a
different media
um
yeah because it really just depends on
the type of story you're trying to tell
and how much the character talks right
so i guess if it's like a third person
game where the the person you control
never says anything that would be a lot
more difficult than a first person game
where you see
you hear your character talking all the
time as you're going through a level um
but
third or first person
is kind of tied to like how close you
are to that character right so
in a novel it can depend on like first
person you only have the information of
that first person the character who's
telling you the story you know what's
going on in their head and their
perception of the world but you don't
know anything else in third person in a
novel um you could have limited um to
only that character or you could know
everything you could know what every
character is thinking all the time and
like sprinkle that information
throughout in a video game
um i feel like whether it's first person
or not
you don't typically hear or know what
other people are thinking unless they
say it out loud so like even it's very
limited you're not going to get a lot of
like
you know omniscient like the narrator is
god some games do that actually but it's
a lot less
common
um so it's really just like
i think the camera view affects more
um
your combat experience i will say there
are a few exceptions that stood out to
me if you played um
oh i'm going to blink on the title
oh crap sorry my brain
what what
is it
so it's a first person you're
experiencing the game um you basically
go back to this island in a house where
you grew up and you're going through the
house and you're encountering you're
like unlocking all these different rooms
and as you do that you see the story of
how all the characters who lived in
those rooms died and you experience it
first person through those characters um
is it the last the final something of um
sorry my brain is terrible with this
kind of stuff i'll look it up later
yes yes thank you i was like i kept
wanting to say like [ __ ] but i was
like that's not the right name but
anyway yes that game um i think the
camera choice was very specific for the
narrative if you experienced that game
in a third person it would not have the
same sensation or emotional impact when
you experience those like death scenes
essentially or like the like
ominousness-ness
you know going through the house the
fact that it's in first person um makes
it feel much more claustrophobic and
emotionally heavy so but that was like i
think a choice that was made
to support the narrative that they were
trying to tell but a lot of games you
know um like for example in fallout 4 i
think it's going to be the same
narrative experience you whether you're
playing in the first person or the third
person camera view
yeah i've always felt like when it comes
to first person versus third person
because uh i've always felt like
set pieces make more sense in a third
person view than because they're set
pieces in first person but you know like
tomb raider uncharted like when you have
those
big epic set pieces i feel like you have
a lot more options in terms of how it
looks and how it's presented if it is a
third person now i do like the uh the
set pieces and like wolfenstein stuff
like that because it it's like
especially when he's uh like he was
going down the hallways in
in the wheelchair and stuff like i feel
like
action paces might do better in a in a
first person perspective because you're
getting a little bit more immersive
because you're actually that person but
as far as like in inter environment set
pieces i feel like they're better in
third because you have a lot more access
to the character because you're not in
the character if that makes sense
well i also think it's been a while
since i played it so i feel like my
memory is like gonna get it wrong but i
remember when i played the newer god of
war they were doing really interesting
stuff with their camera too where in the
combat you were more of like a third
person right um and because it wasn't
really it was like oh it's more
convenient makes the combat better let's
do that but then in certain
you know
narrative heavy moments or emotional
experience type thing the camera did
come in a lot closer and follow those
characters in a cinematic manner
it is interesting how certain developers
do
use both perspectives like for certain
things like uh for instance
destiny i'm a huge destiny fan and the
combat is all first person but when you
pull out that sword
it goes third person naturally and it's
like one of the only times in the
perspective it isn't that's mainly
combat wise uh at that time i don't
think they were really trying to learn
how to make the sword look appealing in
first person so it was more it made more
sense to make it third person uh and i
think it's like one of those things
where it's like
i think both games can do well i think
fallout does a good
way
of creating this world in first person
but keep in mind a lot of these rpgs
especially they give you the option to
do both but i do feel like
a lot of these games might give you the
option but they were designed for one
it's just they're giving you the option
to do the other
well yeah i think i think for me the
interesting aspect of it is what is the
camera doing and when because even a
game like um cyberpunk
a lot of their cinematic stuff was still
third person you know depending you
could see your character or you'd be
like third person walking up to it and
then you would sit down and maybe you'd
only see your hands drinking a glass but
then at certain points in certain scenes
the camera would actually
still show you um and so it's really
interesting what they're doing there so
more so than like just straight up first
or third like you would see in a novel
which like those are kind of your main
choices i think here it's like what is
the camera doing how close is it is it
up high is it low you know it can you
see yourself or not like and those are
all have different effects on the
experience for the player in that moment
you know what's uh did you play it takes
two and a weighs out
yet but i was really enjoying it that's
also couch co-op yeah i feel like that's
a perfect example
of everything coming together making
sense because especially like in a ways
out there's a scenario where one
character is up fighting some individual
like a crane and the other character is
running around the crane trying to catch
up to him and the and the camera's
painting back and forth
showing where they are and then once you
get to the end like the camera's like
this small for one and like this small
for the other like that is a unique way
of using a camera angle
that would make more sense off what they
need it and not off what they have
yeah and that's also a unique discipline
at a lot of studios to be you know a
cinematic designer or you know the
person who's in charge of the camera in
different moments of the game so if
that's something that really interests
you it's a career route that you know
anyone could look into and become an
expert in and then
build that in different games which i
think is super cool
yeah so you know
what is obviously with the pandemic and
stuff that happened uh what was some key
things that changed for you as a writer
like was there was there a lot of
hiccups or because i know some studios
was a little bit more
uh you know remote ready than other
studios but how was it for the writing
portion like
was there like
a lot more like i wouldn't say like red
flags or red tape but was there a lot
more because obviously you guys will
work with highly sensitive stuff uh was
there a
did they make it a lot harder for you to
write for something like the outer
worlds being in a working environment
i actually don't think so at all i think
some departments it was a lot harder for
them but for narrow design and writing
at least what i experienced it was
pretty seamless to switch to a virtual
environment because like okay we're
having meetings in person writing on a
whiteboard or now we're having meetings
on a video call like this and someone's
writing down notes or there's a
whiteboard in the background so it
wasn't all that different also a lot of
what we do is um
you know we meet with the different
people involved talk about all the stuff
maybe one person's play testing
everybody else is watching it and then
you go back and you do your individual
work you know i pull up the tool and i
check out the files and i do my work and
then i test it and i check it in and
then everybody else can see it so it was
like whether i was doing that in the
physical office or my home office here
it didn't change too much
all right so i do have a couple
questions i see in the chat uh i picked
out the ones that make sense obviously
we're not asking quite easy questions
was gaming her first choice when writing
when learning to write was uh that the
first avenue that you wanted
i'm so old that
it was not even like i didn't even
realize game writing was the thing when
i so i really got into writing i want to
say when i was
i mean it kind of started when i was
like i don't know 11 or 12 when you
start exploring like oh i'm writing
little stories and stuff like that and
then when i was 15 i was doing it a lot
like writing short stories with original
characters writing a lot of fan fiction
like me and my friends at school would
like write a notebook and pass it in
class and try not to have the teacher
catch it you know um
so back then i you know i had video
games but a lot of it was like you know
nintendo
you know like mario or yoshi's island or
you know desert strike stuff like that
um so i wasn't thinking a lot the first
game that i really played that i thought
wow this is like it has a impressive
story and it's just because i didn't
play the earlier ones unfortunately but
the first one i played with final
fantasy 10 and i remember thinking like
i'm playing that game right now
it really impacted me and so that
probably started me down the route of
like man you know video game writing is
like a thing just as much as film or
television or novels or comics um
and you know when i was in college i was
doing creative writing
again focusing on fiction um you know
like at that time
they didn't have video game writing
classes that i could take i could take
you know poetry i could take non-fiction
i could take fiction which would be
short stories or novels or there was one
film writing class that i took
and when i was in grad school
after going to conventions i
made friends with an artist a concept
artist who worked at ea and she was like
well you know you love you know fallout
and bioshock and stuff like that why
don't you just try to write for them
because i was thinking what am i going
to do with my life how am i going to get
a job um so that kind of started me down
that route of like yes i would like to
do that because i enjoy game stories so
much and i think it would be really cool
um there were not a lot of studios back
then who hired a lot of writers it would
kind of be like oh there's like one or
two at the entire studio
but eventually
got my foot in the door and just kind of
you know
worked
my way in the industry then um and i
think somewhere like obsidian you know
i've just been really lucky in that
they do like a lot of the games that
they make are very narrative heavy they
you know have a lot of writers in the
studio um we have a pretty robust
narrative department and the
collaboration with other departments is
really fun and cool so i feel like i
definitely found that right fit for me
and a curiosity um
do you communicate because i know when
you was on iop the last time talked
about collaborations with other studios
that microsoft owns do you talk to a lot
of the narrative focused people on other
studios a lot
yeah i would say more so i talk with
narrative people than like a random
programmer or you know like uh maybe
occasionally if an artist or something
would had a narrative question but you
know my area of expertise is kind of
limited to like our tool set and how we
build things so usually it would be
you know a meeting of the minds to try
and be like how do you guys do stuff and
you know what problems did you run into
and just comparing notes that type of
stuff
um i got another question what kind of
key qualities are important when
learning to write for a team and how do
you split up r uh writers
uh that's what they were asking i don't
know if that's something okay yeah again
i think it's really important when
you're
working at a game studio especially if
you're not the only writer there you
know if you're working with other
writers or you're in a team with
other developers the main thing to
remember is like you're just one person
in the team you're not your stuff is not
the most precious you're not the most
important person and it can take a while
like i think everyone
kind of is like hey i like this idea
it's really important to me so it can
take a while to get to the point where
you're like everyone feels that way it's
important to think about the larger
perspective and like what do we have
time for how cool would this be
are other people on board that type of
stuff um and especially with like
if you end up having to share a
character which sometimes happens or
maybe you inherit a character from
someone or do scheduling you have to
move on to a different area and you're
handing off your work to someone else to
maintain it's important to
improve what they have you know you're
going to like polish it up you're going
to bug fix it maybe you're going to add
to it but you know
if you can like save at least the spirit
of what they're trying to accomplish i
think that goes a long way like you
don't always want to come in and just
like steamroll
all the work that's hijacked
yeah
i mean you could but
it's like i know you spent years working
on this character but it's not your
character and it was mocking yeah yeah
like you you could but i just and maybe
sometimes it's called for maybe you're
stepping in because you know the
direction of the character needs to
change um and you've been asked to do
that or you think it's better to do that
but i think if you do that all the time
that other people might you know not
want to give you their stuff
uh so i do uh someone did i only got i'm
only gonna ask two more questions out of
this chat because i do want to let you
go um
so someone asked how many riders is
typically in a triple a game on your
standpoint
uh is it usually i think that would
determine mainly about what type of game
if they take it uh you know narrative
seriously or not because i do feel like
that's one of the things that's made
obsidian such a successful company is
because they're like we care about
gameplay and narrative almost equally uh
so you know i don't know if you can
answer how many writers you guys have i
don't know if that's something that you
could say uh you can answer that if you
want but uh i will give we actually
would have to like
pull it up and count how many we have
across all the different projects but
it's a lot it's a lot yeah we do have a
lot um
some studios i think it depends on how
long the game is in production the size
of the game how
much um writing goes into the game
because a game like obsidian you know if
you're dealing with like hey we've got a
million words in this game versus a game
that's also aaa but maybe only has like
i don't know 30 000 or something like
that that's a big difference um because
i think i could be wrong but i think god
of war um which had an amazing narrative
in my opinion i think they only had like
three or four
um full-time writers on that they might
have had more on contract i'm not sure
but then when i saw the credits for like
um
oh gosh why does my brain always do this
um
i don't know why my brain is blinking
out but basically a different
rpg they had like 17 writers
in the credits so it really just depends
on the studio
and you know
how they decide to staff up
and plus i think it goes off with the
kind of making like god of war is more
of an er like you know kind of a
narrative single straight line type of
game and when you make a game like you
guys generally make like there's a lot
of different branching paths you have a
lot of npcs talking to so you got to
write all that so i think that would
require more people generally so i got
one last question from flame he is an
inspiring writer so uh shout out to
flames he's a good dude
he said question for the royalty when
writing important moments for characters
or stories how do you put yourself in
that scenario to perfectly capture it
wow
it's a deep question man i don't know
does every writer approach a different
i'd be interested to hear from other
people in the chat who write like what
you guys do um i think for myself it
always involves a lot of daydreaming
right playing out different scenarios
trying to imagine how
you would feel or what how you would
react or you know embodying the
character and then um i know pixar talks
about this a lot they're really big into
drawing on your own life experiences and
translating that into the story so it's
like if you
recently had a kid they want you to be
working on a story where that's about
you know a new parent or something like
that because you can directly draw the
unique experiences from your life and
make that movie more authentic and more
emotionally resonant and stuff like that
now a lot of what we do
pure fiction so it's like i'm not ever
going to have a scenario where it's like
oh i just committed mass genocide you
know or something like that so that's
not a case where you draw from you know
one-to-one personal life experience but
maybe you would think about
you know a time that you that motivated
you to
you know make a
bad decision or something like that like
what would compel you to like take more
and more extremes or you know
so you just try and like
what if a lot of things and think about
past experiences or i don't know just
straight up role play and imagine
fantasy different stuff i guess just
what's what you're saying is it just
depends on what you're going through at
the time
uh like you said uh certain other
studios or you know people in other
industries will have you captivate all
she just had a kid so she has a lot of
emotions tied into her her newborn uh so
let's have her write something about
newborns because that would probably you
know uh evolate that type of writing
because that's what she's passionate
about at that time i got a ten dollar
superstar from donald otaku dang i'm
late i'll listen later but great guest
i've just wanted to support while i can
uh you know
i really appreciate you coming on here
that's all the questions we're doing
guys i gotta gotta let her go home man i
gotta let her go home i assume you're at
the studio uh
oh actually no i'm working from my home
office right now but
i saw people walking in the background
so i was like that's my husband oh i
didn't know who i obviously i i didn't
know
to point that out but a lot of people
are in the office right now but we're
doing a hybrid model where like some
people are at home
full-time some people are in the office
certain days some people go in in the
morning and then go home in the
afternoon it's pretty cool i like the
flexibility so
it is just like it's like i said i feel
like
look
we can give criticism on certain things
that's going on
but i do feel like we
we as you know
especially influencers you know uh the
the arm chair developers on on twitter
that feel like they know jobs better
than actual people
that actually do the jobs i feel like we
gotta do a better
a better
thing about
being compassionate to what people do
because
this thing's not easy and it's like you
know what we were saying on just the
branching path alone that's probably the
entire development right there like
that's crazy the amount of work that
goes into something like that uh so you
know i appreciate you coming on giving
more perspective of being a senior
writer because
especially something like writing i'm
not a writer i'm always 100 open with
that we have a website and i'm like i
don't write i don't write i'll uh now
i'll do a video i don't mind doing a
video but me and writing have never got
along i failed ninth grade english twice
so it's just like me and writing don't
get i math i'm okay i'm pretty decent in
math but no not writing uh and it's
always interesting to see
how
people in different industries take
writing different ways
and i love that you came on and just
gave a little bit more perspective of it
was like you know especially working at
a studio like ob city and you know uh
because it'd be i think it's different
than working for someone like obsidian
that is a well-developed studio that's
made multiple games like fallout new
vegas stick-a-truce you know
couture i think it's different from
stuff like that than like a a brand new
studio that doesn't really have a whole
lot to show and hasn't had a history
because i feel like you
will put yourself more on uh i got to
prove myself more than the average
person because you're looking back and
you're like look what they've made and
i'm involved in their newer stuff so i
got to be on my top of my game there is
a lot of pressure onto it that a lot of
people won't give
you know people credit for it especially
how
extra twitter is on judging stuff
you know i think too is um
one thing i like to think about it is
like
i'm like literally everybody i work with
it came in kind of the same way which is
like they're really big fans of video
games they like playing video games and
they want to work on video games they
tried really hard to get into the
industry and then eventually got in and
now they're making video games and
they're trying to do it the best that
they can
um we're still human so mistakes happen
or you know maybe i like especially like
have you seen that meme where it's like
you know how you picture it in your head
and it's like the picasso or um van gogh
version of like oh this is beautiful and
then how you do it is like the stick
figure like the execution didn't match
up so i feel like if that even happens
to like someone with a ton of experience
like i'll always be like this is the
ideal version of my head and then when
i'm trying to build it i'm like oh why
is it not perfect right so um and
there's only so many like
time
you know resources and then priority of
like how important is this in the game
overall versus something else you know
do you want to work on this game or like
do we want to make this game for like 15
years or do we want to try and get it to
people in like
three years something like that so um
but i do think that most of people here
really care they're really passionate
they're doing their best and they also
listen to people so you know when we put
a game out and it gets certain criticism
we try to improve that on the next thing
that we do
um so yeah but i mean i appreciate
people playing you know i want to like
bring entertainment into people's lives
i want to make
you know your life better for having
experienced our stuff i don't ever want
to like accidentally waste someone's
time or something like that so it's like
you know we're trying our best and
hopefully we're able to execute on it
but i guess you can't ever always you
know perfectly pull everything off so
you can't satisfy 100 of people it's
impossible you can only aim to you know
try to satisfy as many people as
possible but you know i appreciate you
coming on megan uh you know you could
plug your twitter and stuff if you want
to i know you're not really on there a
whole whole lot yeah i did
not i do much
i do see you like promoting books and
stuff on there so you know maybe you
want to promote uh promote uh some type
of work that that's going in
um
well i i haven't
my book was like two years ago so i feel
bad but yeah i mean if people are
interested in for an occasional
tweet i'm a fictivate but i would say
yeah during the pandemic i started and i
don't know if anybody else has really
felt this way or not but it might have
been like as i got a little older or
maybe as a because of the pandemic but i
started feeling like social media like
too much exposure was like increasing my
anxiety or maybe i was putting too many
hours a day into it and so i basically
just cut out
the majority of social media use in my
day-to-day life and only check in
occasionally and i feel much more like
chill and relaxed for it
what's funny is i think because i'm like
a content creator i'm a podcaster
um
we're literally the sleeve of twitter so
we get the most feedback from everyone
like look developers might get feedback
off their games but most people don't
know who to talk to for a thing like if
if they don't like something that
obsidian made they're gonna blame
obsidian as a whole like no individual
person really maybe besides the lead you
know the leads uh but content creators i
make content every day people don't like
so i'm constantly and i think because of
that
i've
i've just breathed in all that all of
that and it doesn't bother me anymore
it used to bother me it used to bother
me like the comments section that that's
the people will tell you that all the
time don't read the comment section i
read the comment section i don't care
yeah so yeah i appreciate you coming on
and uh you know uh it's like i said i'm
gonna do more of these guys uh like i
didn't get to every question because i
made a very vocal because i know how
these chat is
uh you know because when it comes to
educational stuff
you'll have less people show up because
it's not entertaining you know obviously
i'm not i'm not trying to amp everything
up 24 7. but i appreciate you coming on
and until next week you know i i will
have a devon next week uh hopefully you
guys enjoy it's it's it's a it's a
turn-based rpg so i hope you guys enjoy
it and until next time this is gaming
addict and and megan and uh we we we
hope you guys have a good day peace
see you guys thank you